-Thanks for coming back
on the show.
You know, I'm a big fan.
I want to congratulate you,
first of all, on "Glass Onion."
Big hit movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nominated for an Oscar.
-Yeah.
-One of the biggest films.
Congratulations.
You got to reunite
with Daniel Craig.
-I did.
Yeah, I got to reunite with him.
And it was weird
because it was like
getting to know him
all over again.
And he was such --
really such --
'Cause he's so different then
when he's filming "Bond."
When he films "Bond,"
I think he just has so much --
You know, it's so stressful,
and he's got so much weight
and so physical,
it takes a toll on him.
-Did you get to hang out
with him much when he's Bond?
-We hung out --
No, not that much.
Kind of, you know,
in between takes,
they kind of dragged him off,
and they probably were
icing him up and preparing him.
He really physically puts
himself through it on "Bond."
-Didn't you break his leg
or something?
-I did not break his leg.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought you broke his leg
or something.
-I did not break his leg.
-Yeah, you broke James Bond's --
-For the record,
I did not break his leg.
-But did he have a mishap
where his leg ended up broken.
-His knee needed surgery.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?!
-But it was not my fault.
-All right.
-We were tussling around,
and his knee popped and --
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah.
And then we were tussling around
some more,
and then my nose was broke.
This was the train fight scene,
and it was really one of
the hardest fight scenes
I've ever done in my life.
-But I did read that,
though, right?
The leg thing, then he had
to wait till it healed.
Then, you healed,
and you did the scene again,
and you and broke your nose.
-Yeah.
It's like splattered all over.
-Oh, my gosh.
-He starts going, "I broke
his nose, I broke his nose!"
I said, "You did.
But I'm all right."
[ Laughter ]
I'm a wrestler.
I can do this.
And then -- yeah.
And then, there was a point
we were filming "Glass Onion,"
and we were in Greece.
And just --
It was a beautiful day.
And we were sitting there in
beautiful, comfortable clothes.
And I just looked at him,
I said, "Man, isn't it great
that we're on a film
where we're not
beating the [bleep]
out of each other?"
[ Laughter ]
And he just started laughing,
but it was.
-Just to get to know each other.
You're both good dudes.
-Thank you.
-I want to talk about
"Guardians of the Galaxy"
because --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're beloved.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But you just confirmed
that this year will be
the last time
we'll see you as Drax.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-I think -- yeah.
I think --
Yeah, it's weird.
I don't know why it's,
like, news.
I feel like it's -- you know, so
this is my seventh film as Drax.
-Is it seven?
-Yeah, seven.
And my third "Guardians."
It was like our trilogy.
That's kind of what we all
signed up for, to do a trilogy.
And I think this is gonna be --
you know, this will be
the last version of our
"Guardians of the Galaxy."
And it's --
-Is it hard to walk away?
-It's hard, but it's time.
It's, like, time,
and it's the perfect exit.
We all had those perfect
kind of character arcs
and such a storybook ending.
I constantly relate it to the
way I ended my wrestling career.
I ended it on a storybook note.
And I would never go back
and tarnish that.
And it's the same with this.
With Drax, I just got to end
the perfect way.
And I would never sign up
for another, you know, job
as Drax just to get a paycheck.
It's just, I would tarnish that,
and I won't do it.
-Really?
I respect that.
I love that.
-Yeah, thank you.
[ Applause ]
You did such a great job.
We'll miss Drax.
But I do want to talk about
your WWE career because
we got to know you as Batista.
-Yeah.
-And last time
you were on the show,
we showed an action figure.
And that was cool.
And we saw
that there's a new one out.
I just want to show everyone.
Here's the new action figure
for Batista out now.
Look at this.
And I like this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
You look good.
My question is this, though.
I don't know if you guys
can see this.
Can you zoom in?
Why is there a table lamp?
[ Laughter ]
Is that a -- that's a lamp?
-That is a question
for the ages.
I don't know.
You know, this is so funny,
because this is kind of a repop
of my original one,
which is one
of my first action --
my first solo action figure.
And for some reason, in that
one, they stuck a floor lamp in.
And I could never figure it out.
-Did you do something?
-Batista complete
with floor lamp.
-Yes, so, you have a floor lamp
in this one.
-And this one has --
[ Laughter ]
And this one not only has a
lamp, but it has extra hands.
And I don't --
[ Laughter ]
Am I -- do I take off my hands
or replace them with hands
to remove -- to place --
to gently place the lamp
on the table?
-Did you do bits?
Did you throw lamps?
-Never.
Nobody -- as far as I know,
nobody in the history
of professional wrestling
has ever used a lamp
as a foreign object.
-Where would you find a lamp?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Where would you plug it in?
-Why did they put a lamp
with my action figure?
-I love that
it's your thing now.
-Somebody tell me.
I guess.
-That's your thing now.
-I do love --
I love some interior design.
[ Laughter ]
-That can't be why.
-I know that sounds funny,
but I do love --
-Yeah.
Well, that's interesting.
-I don't know.
-Yeah.
Maybe we'll see it some time
on an HGTV show
where you're like --
-[ Gasps ]
-You know what I'm saying?
And it'll finally
be revealed why.
-Light bulb.
-Yeah.
Literal -- literal light bulb.
Hello!
-And that's our next skit.
-Gotta call nine-fun-fun.
Exactly.
-Somebody call nine-fun-fun.
-I want to talk about
"Knock at the Cabin."
-Yeah.
-This is scary.
I mean, this is a thriller.
M. Night Shyamalan.
One of the greatest out there.
-I love him, man.
-He's unbelievable.
-I just love him.
-But you're great in the movie.
You guys --
He's a good director, huh?
-Yeah.
He's a --
Yeah, he's a master director.
But he's also
just a good human being.
-Yeah.
-More importantly,
he's a good human being.
-Do you --
You work, obviously,
well together.
But how did you
get hooked up with him?
Did he find you?
Did you find him?
-Well, he originally --
So, my agent sent me an e-mail.
It said that Night
wanted to talk to me.
-Yeah.
-And so, I flipped out
'cause I've lined up to work
with master directors.
And so, I flipped out.
I sent them back about
20 e-mails with 20 questions.
"What do you want to talk about?
What do you want to do?
Is there a film?
Is there a project?"
And they said, "No.
I mean, we don't know.
He won't say."
And he's --
You know, Night's very secretive
about his projects.
Anyway, they set up the call.
And I fanned out.
I fanboyed for about an hour.
That's what it was.
-Yeah. Good.
-That's what our call was.
-Why not?
-And then I was expecting him
to tell me about something,
I'm waiting for it,
waiting for it,
and it never came.
He said, "Okay.
Well, it was
great talking to you."
And I got off the call.
[ Laughter ]
And I had to call my agents and
say he didn't mention anything.
And so, anyway, we had about
two more of those calls.
And then, finally, I think
it was after the third one,
he finally says,
"Well, you know, I got a project
that I've been working on.
I think I have a role for you.
Are you interested?"
And I said,
"Yes, of course I'm interested."
So, he sent me the script.
I read it.
And it was very late at night.
And the next morning,
I called him and I said,
"I'd kill for this role.
What do I have to do?
Who do I have to kill
for this role?"
He said,
"You don't have kill anybody.
You don't have to do anything.
I want you for this role."
He said, "Dave, basically,
you know, I've been talking
to you, and I wanted
to know who you were,
and, basically,
you are this guy."
So, yeah. He says,
"You're perfect for this role.
It was tailor-made for you."
-Did you read the ending,
and did you read the whole
thing, the whole script?
-I did on this one, because I'm
very involved in the ending.
-Yeah.
-But typically, I --
You're stooging me out.
-Well, I am because --
Again, I did a little research.
-I am guilty of not reading
the endings of scripts of movies
I'm in because --
[ Laughter ]
-"Glass Onion," I read
that you didn't read the ending.
-I didn't. No.
[ Laughter ]
I hope Rian's not pissed at me.
I totally didn't.
-No, because you want
to be surprised?
-I do. I want to --
I'm a fan.
I want to go -- if I'm not
involved in the end,
I want to go,
and I watch it like a fan.
-I know, but you're in it!
You have to read the script.
-Yeah, but I kind of can
get a sense of what I need to do
just by --
[ Laughter ]
I'm not unprofessional.
I know my dialogue.
-You do.
[ Applause ]
You're very professional.
-Yeah, I want to be surprised.
-Well, this one's another
M. Night scary thriller.
How do we set it up for people
without giving too much away?
-I'm so bad at this.
-I know.
I should be good at this.
-So, I say that -- all right.
So, there's four strangers
who show up uninvited
to this cabin to convince
this wonderful family
that they have to sacrifice
one of the family members
in order to prevent
the apocalypse.
[ Laughter ]
-For real?
These four strangers show up
to a family, and they're like,
"What's up?"
-"Look, you guys are gonna
have to kill one of
the family members."
-"One of you have to die --"
-"Or the world's gonna end."
"So, choose."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, it's -- yeah.
It goes there.
And it's --
Actually, it's unbelievable.
It's a super fun ride.
It's insane.
I don't want to even
show you what happens.
But, man, oh, man.
Fantastic.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dave Bautista
in "Knock at the Cabin."
Check it.
-You have to understand that
we cannot and will not choose
who has to be sacrificed
for you.
And just as importantly,
we cannot act for you.
You cannot kill yourselves.
-We're not choosing anyone.
We're not sacrificing anyone.
Not now, not ever.
-Even if it means the death of
everyone else in the world?
-Yes.
Even if I believe the world
was at stake, which I don't,
that's what it means.
I would watch the world die
a hundred times over
before having --
-Christ!
Waste of time.
They're never gonna
choose to do this.
And I don't blame them.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dave Bautista!
"Knock at the Cabin"
is in theaters this Friday!